well good day everyone it's a pleasure
for me to share with you how Innovations
can happen in ior the business ecosystem
and these are value chain Innovations as
you know the Innovations can happen in
multiple ways so within business within
governments within the public sector and
we often times think of Innovations as
product Innovations or service
Innovations products of course we all
know is a new product a new feature a
new functionalities and that of course
has tremendous values but what sometimes
we have overlooked are the opportunities
where these are non product Innovations
the Innovations is about how you work
with your partners how you deal with
your customer bases and how you interact
with the public at large and there are
new ways to do that and in fact many of
these ways can lead to values so what do
we mean by a value chain and an
ecosystem so let me show you an example
suppose we are dealing with a mobile
phone company a mobile phone company
that makes cell phones of course most
natural we would think of the mobile
phone companies as a Manufacturing
Company because there are suppliers to
the components to the various pieces uh
some assemblies that eventually you have
to put them together and distribute it
through channels through channels of
retailers through channels of carriers
and eventually getting to the consumers
so that's the traditional way of looking
at the value chain but we also recognize
very quickly that this is not sufficient
because if you want to be a successful
mobile phone company you have to look at
the So-Cal extended value chain the
extended value chain would involve uh
content as we know mobile phone today is
not just a device uh for communication
but lots of interactions really related
to apps related to games related to
messaging and so on contents
infrastructure and how can we deliver
the content in a seamless way requiring
the Big T Telecom systems uh involving
carriers who would be the one that
distribute product and contents and even
Payment Systems as well and other many
many Merchants but again that's not
sufficient if you think about the much
bigger picture a mobile phone
Works under a much much bigger Authority
ecosystem the ecosystems would involve
like financial institutions governments
the governments legal systems who allow
you to operate in a certain way
especially when you're talking about
cross borders um and these days
Logistics providers that perhaps would
also help you to deliver products and
processes which resulted from the
transactions that happen in your phones
the new technologies that being
developed and ultimately many many in
many many settings even the nonprofit or
non-government organizations the
activist may also have a role depending
on whether your operations your New
Concept your new towers station may
impact uh constituents and they may be
organized to either support you or in
some cases uh hurt you so in a way we
have to manage the whole ecosystem to be
successful and when I talk about
Innovations in the ecosystems what I
meant is how do we interact with all
these constituents in an Innovative way
a new way a new way that would enable
you to be more successful and it's
sometimes not just you yourself being
successful but it could also be how the
rest of the ecosystem also benefit from
it so it's not like this is a zero sum
game that if I win some part of the
ecosystems may hurt but this is not
always the case and so we have to
recognize that if it's a case where some
wins and some loses and we have to
account for it and you have to find a
way to reduce the losses and perhaps
even got those losses into winds so
that's the reason why we have to look at
it from the ecosystem perspective
because otherwise if you have a
successful product but by yourself you
may not be able to get to realistic
benefits and success in the marketplace
because some parts of the
ecosystems could not see the benefits
and they may actually act in opposite
ways that may reduce the chance of your
success so what can we do for
innovations that are Beyond products and
services in the ecosystems so here today
I want to share with you six ways in
which those Innovations can occur these
are by no means exhaustive but I want to
highlight them because they are most per
have significant and these are all based
on examples and based on the work that
I've done and observed over the years so
I want to share with you and some of
them may now become very standard
practices that companies must do if you
want to be successful you want to make
sure you have the right relationship
with your partners but in what way can
we improve those relationship so I hope
that this sharing would enable us to
perhaps get some nuggets that you'll be
able to get stimulated into new thoughts
on how you would deal with your
ecosystem Partners these six elements
are as follows first is that there
always Innovation which is come
sometimes at this is bread and brother
for us to look at your own self the
innovations that happen inside your own
self and and that because you yourself
is a part of the ecosystem so don't
forget that we can also start with your
own self ways to do things differently
processes that would result in
improvements or in result in efficiency
gains and cycle time gains Etc so that I
call within node Innovations second one
would be linkages because as I mentioned
we are one part of the ecosystem so
there are many many players some direct
some indirect and those involve links
links could be in the form of
communication information sharing or it
could be in the form of transportation
Logistics and so all of those are
linkages and how can we work under the
linkages so this time is not just you
yourself but we have to work with the
partners so that the linkages can be
strengthened so that the linkages can be
done in a different
way the third one is we are becoming
more Global we are a global Enterprise
most of us are becoming yeah even if you
may start as a company that is more
Regional based but very quickly if you
want to build a scale you have to deal
with a global global
ecosystem and it could be that not your
immediate suppliers but your supplier
suppliers and somewhere you may be
getting those minerals from somewhere in
Africa AFC and therefore you are part of
the global global ecosystem when we are
in a ecosystem that involve the global
Enterprise we have borders borders and
also different Nooks that you have to
deal with and I think the integration
how you integrate how you work with them
and how you are able to maybe using
information or using planning uh using
collaboration our ways that you can
develop new way of working with others
and so that's the cross notes
integration that I'm referring
to workflow
Innovation would simply be you even if
you want to deliver the same products
and the same surface the methods and the
ways the
sequence um of the workflow that would
be involved can be
changed and that way the workflow
Innovation may result in New doing one
step before the other or doing things in
parallel or in some cases eliminating
some of the steps
totally the next one is I call
reconfiguration reconfiguration is also
kind of like a very significant
byproduct of the globalization when we
talk about globalization they are all
over the world and there would of course
be borders that we have to cross and
there are also lead times that we have
to deal with um countries that are far
away sometimes may require more time to
get to of course this is
not Universal because sometimes a
country that is closed enough but
because you do not have the right
processes in place or because the
government custom clearance processes
are so difficult that actually it may
take you more time and efforts to get
the products in and out so we recognize
all of these both the strengths of the
countries the Excellence in terms of the
expertise of the countries in interal
capabilities uh and the cost economies
Transportation cost and the trade
agreements and also the government
incentives that would require us to
reconfigure your network and when you
reconfigure the network that's an
innovation in an Innovative way coming
up with a new way that really would
result in much higher efficiency and
responsiveness the final one is perhaps
the biggest of all and often times is
most difficult is the relationship side
so that even if you're working still
with the same company I'm still using
the same configuration and I am still
doing the same kind of information
exchange and the same workflow but the
relationship that we have with the
partners and by the relationship it
could be the contractual relationship it
could be who does what how do we perform
each uh performance measurements uh
managed across companies and the roles
and responsibilities the incentives that
we put in place all of those for
business relationships and I think that
is something that we can also focus on
so let me go through this one by one
Innovation within a node so this time
we're supposed to be zero in one node
which I think I use the diagram here and
then zero in the yellow portion which is
one note inside a note I think
Innovation can occur let me give you an
example of this e-commerce company a
fast growing e-commerce company in China
called Den yen is a e-commerce company
just like Amazon that we are familiar
with in the most part of the world and
they are a fast growing company this
company is amazing is the growth is
exponential and Walmart has invested
significantly into this company and so
they are part of the Walmart Empire now
but this
company the Thrive of this company
resulted in the companies having now an
explosive customer base and the orders
are exponentially growing every day but
what they found is that the ability to
Pick and Pack inside Warehouse becomes a
bottleneck customers order all kinds of
things all kinds of baskets and the
warehouses are becoming bigger and
bigger and the stock keeping units are
huge how can you pick and pack and send
the product out on the same day or even
within the same hour and be able to
deliver to the customers on time becomes
a major major differentiation so what
this company focus on is using
information and they have a host of
information Technologies invested
in aut processing and customer service
uh softwares product management software
warehouse management systems
transportation management systems and
CRM Etc and here is what the companies
discover is that as a result of that
kind of innovation this is called inside
the not Innovation inside even a
warehouse in this case inside a
warehouse how can we manage this well
amazingly is that on average what they
found is that a customer on average
would order 16 items
to them grocery items books and so on
and a typical typical Warehouse that
this company has that 70,000 stock
keeping units and it's huge 25,000
square meters so if you have to look for
these 16 items and put them together
pack them together into one basket and
then package them label them and then
ship them out how long do you think it
would
take gangu who is the chairman of the
company who was actually former formerly
the vice president at the Amazon on and
he post me this question and he says
that as a result of the tremendous
integrated Information Systems
intelligent smart way of putting the
right item in the right place in the
warehouse is only 127 seconds on average
this is amazing of course sometimes
longer sometimes shorter depending on
the basket but the average that he was
able to achieve is
127 seconds that's about 2 minutes 2
minutes to be able to retrieve of course
there are lots of Auto information
involved in the warehouse but still this
is admirable that's the kind of within
note Innovation that will result in
tremendously OU Val change agility is
sometimes the differentiation sometimes
is also the way that you compete well
and e-commerce in China is thriving and
it's very important speed is everything
especially in an emerging economy like
China customer service is everything
customer experience is everything so
we're seeing this very interesting
exciting things
and that's just one example and I think
there are many many other examples but I
just want to highlight this to show that
there are things to be done inside a
node but what about linking noes linking
two noes like we have two noes here but
we're focusing on not the inside of each
of the noes but the linkage between two
noes well as I mentioned earlier is that
because this globalization globalization
resulted in sometimes the two noes being
in two different countries in a study by
the World Bank which I collaborated in a
few years ago what I found is that often
times is not the distance between two
countries that resulted in difficulties
in linkages but it's crossing the border
how easy how fast can you cross the
border how many signatures do you
require from the custom office to sign
off before you can ship how many
inspections are required how many
documents do you need and all of those
were steps so in a recent study that
Professor Warren housan uh at the
management science and engineering
department of Stanford we collaborated
together on studying a very simple
simple qu this problem is China to us
trade the trade process involved if you
want to ship products from China to the
US it turns out there are over 120 steps
involved just to get products in and out
of the country we're not talking about
even manufacturing and transportation
we're talking about just all the steps
that you need in order for the
governments to allow allow you to ship
products out in and
out and linkage innovation in this case
would be what can we do so that those
linkages can be much better and what we
found is that there are two ways two
ways to do that one of course is to make
every step faster and that's more
internal like internal within not
processes within note processes is that
you can do something digitized or you
can have the documents prepar ahead of
time and then you'll be more efficient
and you'll be more accurate and more
reliable so that you don't have errors
but the other one is to see if there are
steps that you can completely change
eliminate because of the fact that you
have Assurance because you have the
government's approval be ahead you are
trusted party and you provide the
information ahead of time ter to the US
Customs office and you able to perhaps
skip some steps parallel processing some
steps elimination of some steps and
those are the linkage Innovation that
resulted in much faster short cyle time
much more reliable processes less
Capital tied up and of course you get
pay faster if you can ship things faster
huge benefits we call this the it Anda
linkage improvements the it enabled
linkage improvements benefits the
manufacturer who is shipping things out
benefits the retailers or the shippers
who is in importing and it also benefits
those intermediaries like Banks who also
have haveit to tie up if the processes
are slow they also would get money back
in in a much less timely fashion
exporters benefit importers benefit and
that's an example of how linkage design
can be done faster linkages are about
Transportation linkages about logistics
here because I also have been working in
the developing economies as well as
Louise has described my bio I also
increasingly are looking at how we can
use value chain Innovations in
developing economies and here is an
example in Zambia in Zambia the linkages
are very challenging because people are
not maintaining their vehicles well and
so we have a lot of these Health
ambulances and the motorcycles they were
very new actually two years old three
years old and they are abandoned they're
abandoned because they don't have the
lack they lack spare parts or because
they did not maintain them well so it's
amazing it's sad to see so many
abandoned abandoned vehicles as a result
many of the people who live in rural
areas have to walk to a health clinic
because there is no vehicles the nurse
and the doctors could not visit them
because they don't have the right
vehicles and motorcycles and so on so
this group riders for health which I've
been working with is an NGO and they
focus on motorcycles and how they can do
the right preventive maintenance that
would extend the life of the vehicles
and also have a complete solution so
that they'll be able to provide the oil
filters and all these repare paaths to
get the motorcycles up all the time and
today the difference is stering here is
a picture of the nurse on riders for
health riding on the riders for health
vehicle and he is now able to visit
remote Villages and take care of sick
children take care of the many many many
needs in a Health Region and that allow
Health Care to be improved and that's
simple example of how focusing on
linkages focusing on the link of
Transportation link can make a
difference the next Innovation that I
want to share with you would be now this
time I have two noes but I'm not just
focusing on the link of Transportation
link Logistics link or cross water I'm
looking at the information managements
Within These two noes the planning
processes Within these noes and what I
can do and I call that integrating the
no integrating them so that they're do
noes but they hopefully by working
together in coordinating them together
they would act like just one note so we
don't have the organization barrier one
simple way is visibility one simple way
Innovation is information that often
times the two notes could not work as
well as one single note is because they
don't have the full information I don't
know what's going on at your site so you
have sales you have demand forecast you
have new products
in the road map and you know when you
want to recycle the products or generate
a new product and the next product will
come out so that the existing product
will become Obsolete and I need to put
in place the plan to recycle the plan to
retrieve the old products or I have
changed my production plan but if I am a
supplier I'm Upstream I did not know
that ahead of time I did not have the
full information ahead of time I would
have distorted information distorted
view I call that the boo web in fact the
boo web is distorted view of what is the
demand information time stream my
response time would not be fast I cannot
prepare my capacity and resulted in high
inventory and the planning cycle becomes
SL so simple simple things like that
just the right sharing of information is
an innovation this is a simple kind of a
basic innovation of having the right
information shared same way that
information from Upstream from the
supplier can also be shared with the
customer on what is a working process
when will the product be arriving the
some of the uh estimated arrival time
and if there any delay alert you ahead
of time confirm the quantity that I'm
shipping to you and any of the updates
in capacity plans and inventory plans
that allow the customers to react better
if there are problems that allow the
customers to be able to proactively plan
and optimize my going forward what I
should be doing and that also enable me
to then in turn share the information
with my own own customers I think this
is really again another way of having
linkages more than just a linkage but
integrating the two
noes amazingly that even though you may
think that wow this is so simple and
straightforward companies should be
sharing all this
information I found in fact we still
have a long way to go this kind of
innovation that's why I'm still listing
them as an innovation because for some
companies they haven't been doing that
here is a survey that I did in 2012 with
the semm world and the survey was done
with the chief supply chain officers of
the world now these are people who may
have a title of Chief supply chain
officers or the vice president of Supply
Chain management or directors of supply
chain Logistics operations and these are
similar titles so these are people who
run supply chain operations in
multinational companies and a survey was
conducted and with a large number of
reply 1,340 replies and one of the
questions that we ask is do you have
visibility and that you are able to
monitor the social and environmental
responsibility performances of your
supply chain social and environmental
responsibility could be like carbon
emissions do they have violations do
they have Labor violations do they have
social violations and so all those are
responsibility
performances and it's interesting that
let me uh explain the the pie chart
here you can see that blue is the ideal
the blue
would be for the executives that says
that I actually am able I am able to see
and monitor my whole key supply network
my suppliers my key suppliers my
supplier suppliers and I'm able to see
whether there are violations or whe How
well they're doing in Social and
environmental
responsibility but the the extreme case
is that about 10% of them says that I
have nothing I know nothing 40 % 44% and
the left hand side is environmental
measures and the right hand side is
social
responsibility and you can see about 45
44% says that I only know about my own
self that is if it's my factory my
warehouse yes I do know what it means is
that there is a big gap the big gap is
that a lot of companies either do not
have visibility of their immediate
suppliers and those who do may only have
their immediate suppliers and only about
20 % have full visibility so without
visibility how can you improve that's
why I think I I like this an example of
a website in China called IP IP is a
website that collects information on all
kinds of environmental violations in
China throughout whole China and you can
click on the website and you can
discover if you have a supplier
suppliers in the far remote region or
some Town you'll be able to see whether
there have been violations and whether
they have fixed the problems that's the
kind of visibility that we need we need
to have extended visibility because
otherwise it's very dangerous very
difficult for you to manage things well
as well as You're vulnerable so I do
believe in this kind of integration
another kind of
integration is knowledge integration
knowledge integration is an example that
I'm illustrating here where
Walmart collaborated with wall lbert in
terms of
knowledge it's it's an example of a
exceptional Heat Wave this is like a
while ago in Florida where the heat wave
resulted in the growth or of the
population of mosquitoes which resulted
in a lot of people get beaten by the
mosquitoes and the mosquitoes resulted
in a huge search in demand for the drugs
for the for the medicines for the
ointment that water lbert made to treat
the mosquito bites now Walmart was not
able to figure out that there could be
such a search in demand by themselves
because Walmart was not a product
company they don't have the Deep product
knowledge so they are a retailer while
Warner Lambert being a product company
knew the linkages that Heatwave is
linked to mosquito mosquito is linked to
bikes and bikes is linked to the demand
for their ointments and so the two
companies started collaboration saying
there is a need for not just information
exchange but knowledge exchange
knowledge exchange resulted in this
collaboration so that I'll be
enlightened I'll be ahead of time know
that this heat wve is something you can
forecast you can get it from the
observatory that that's the heat wave
coming and I am able to because of the
collaboration with for Lambert be able
to stock up all the ointments on my
source to avoid the stock house so
knowledge exchange is an other kind of
innovation workflow Innovation this time
is about how you do work it's not about
information it's not about knowledge but
it's only physically how you do things
here is an example from hul packet H
packet used to make the Deskjet printer
it's the inkjet printer in their
factories they used to long time ago
when they were still manufacturing
before they Outsource so what it means
is that they would build those printers
in the factories and customize them for
different markets and then they would
ship the products to distribution
centers and the Distribution Center
could be in Europe could be in Singapore
could be in North America or South
America now once the product has been
customized it has a language in it it
has the power cour it has the um
language in in manuals and sometimes
even the software loaded would have a
language requirements so the products
become languaged languaged with German
Spanish French and the problem is that
by doing
so once the product hits the
Distribution Center is already localized
localized meaning that you cannot sell a
German language printer in France very
hard yeah so that kind of inflexibility
hurts HP so what we did is that they
change the workflow now here is the
workflow very intelligent the workflow
is that they still build the product at
the factory the core product in the
factory but the customization of the
product into different languages happen
in distribution because distribution is
closer to the market as you see more
French customers coming you just
customize more French printers in the DC
or the customers in Spain has declined
in sales and then you customize less so
the customization resulted in what is
called postponement beautiful and that's
the workflow change but they don't stop
there interestingly is that as HV start
offshoring meaning they Outsource to
fonics and contract manufacturers then
they offshore to LCC lowcost countries
in China in sapalo they discover that
the cost of manufacturing is so
attractive low cost that maybe this time
they should have the customization back
in those countries because it's
attractive cost attractiveness so they
move the customization back to China
they move them back to the lowcost
countries which is a way to continue
improve uh the process of cost
advantages but today they did another
step which what they found is that
customization still is better to be
close to the market because the market
changes is often times German printer
demand and the French demand they're all
fluctuating hard to predict it's still
desirable to do it close to the market
but close to the market if the
Distribution Center is in Germany is
very expensive is in Holland it's very
expensive what they did now is they
customize them I call it near Market in
Hungary Budapest which is Eastern Europe
lower cost than Germany but still close
to the market or in guara in Mexico so
is not us but is close to the US and
lower cost so you can see this Evolution
that I show you here are flow Innovation
workflow Innovation means that I change
where I do things depending on what is
the right right place right time to do
the best things reconfiguration this
time is massaging where I do things why
do I need to REM massage them from time
to time I think one of the factors there
are many factors one of the factors I
use this chart to show increasingly
there are lots and lots of trade
agreements this chart shows from WTO the
number of trade agreement signed between
countries between regions over time and
you can see this is exponentially
growing if you look at the line the
black line shows how many of them are
still surviving the red line shows
cumulative trade agreements that have
been signed over time of course some of
them have expired some of them has been
canceled so the red the the red is
cumulative and the black line shows the
surviving one still big one you can
notice even look at the black line the
surviving ones are still huge the huge
number of trade agreements means that
you must not set up a value chain and
never revisit it again because cost
change economic change and Trade
Agreement change look at renold renold
built the Logan car originally in
Romania for Eastern Europe mostly and
North Africa but they discovered that
the demand in West Europe also has been
surging Spain Germany France they always
like the products so they have to expand
the facility where do they choose to
expand interestingly they chose to build
a new Factory in Morocco why Morocco you
may ask why Morocco of course there are
many factors but one of the factors it
turns out is because Morocco has a trade
agreement with Romania so that the
engines built in Romania can be custom
free to Morocco and then Romania joined
EU so part of that is that the Romanian
built engines qualified as EU parts and
so as long as you ship enough of the
engines into Morocco the cars built in
Morocco is viewed as a EU car and it's
taxfree going to Europe so all these are
significant trade considerations that
you can have to build in reconfiguring
your network is tremendous Advantage so
you don't do it for the sake of saving
uh not not cheating but basically you
you really need to be aware of these
kind of trade agreements so that you
don't get burned or you also hopefully
can take advantage of the final final
innovation I mentioned earlier is this
complex business relationships business
relationship this time is more than just
you and unle potentially partner but it
could be multiple partners it's all the
relationship what kind of relationship
are we talking about here is a simple
beautiful example of an old example but
I use the old example to highlight this
importance in the video Used to Be video
of course today nobody would rent video
at the Blockbuster but used to this is
what happened to Blockbuster many years
ago when Blockbuster was still a
powerful company they would buy BL
Bluster being a retailer they would
buy the videos from The Producers MGM
and fox and so on and the manufacturing
cost of the video is very low but they
usually would sell at a very high cost
as a result the retailer given that is
expensive to buy one they don't want to
stock a lot when they don't want to
stock a lot often times they stock out
so the customer is coming in for the
weekend and this is really the video
that I want to rent and you could not
find that movie you have to rent
something second past so so
what the Blockbuster and the producer
have struck a
landmark contractual Innovation is to
sell for the producer to sell the video
almost at cost to the retailer so the
manufacturers are not making any money
much money from selling and the retailer
would sell much more but in return the
retailer would share 50% of the revenue
with the producer this was a fantastic
deal this is a complete change in the
contractual relationship between two
companies and everyone benefit so this
is a simple example of contractual
relationship of course this is no longer
valid today given that video rental is
no longer the the way that people watch
movies re-engineering the financial flow
these are Financial flows Rel resulted
in contractual relationship between
companies special payment terms special
discounts how can we do inventory
Consignment and using return contracts
or using wholesale price discounts
Revenue sharing contracts like
Blockbuster has using price protection
meaning that if the price drops in the
future I'll give you the discount back
and rebase all these are instruments
business relationship instruments
remember Prius when Prius was first
introduced in the US from Toyota what
Prius discover is that the old way or
the traditional way of selling cars is
that toyoto ship cars into the dealers
and the dealers have to shoulder the
inventory risk because the dealer has a
payment term and they have to pay Toyota
but if the dealer cannot sell the car
they have to do the M down at the end of
the year they would do whatever and
sales and so on so the inventory risk
was with the dealers but normally for
Camry and Corolla the risk is small but
for a new car at the time when Prius was
a brand new hybrid coming in it was a
highrisk car because at that time hybrid
was not well established and it's an
uncertain car
Americans will they buy into the concept
of a hybrid so it's high risk plus the
dealers have to invest in special power
charger in spare parts and so all are
significant Investments so to the
dealers it's unequal risk they would be
shouldering much bigger risk the Beauty
and the I would see the innovation of
Reas is to change that business
relationship by saying that I will take
the risk of inventory away from you I
ship the products I hold the inventory
you don't have to hold inventory you
just hold the DMO units if you sell one
I ship you one if you sell two I ship
you two so I am balancing the risk and
give the incentive for the dealers to
work harder to sell the car for you this
is a beautiful business relationship for
the startup phase not now now is a
mature Market Prius is no longer
uncertain and and unknown so you don't
have to do that but for the initial
phase is a business relationship Saturn
has done the same thing even though
Saturn doesn't exist as a car separate
car uh the division anymore what used to
happen is that Saturn discovered that
they Saturn spos Saturn Service Parts
operations serve the dealers that they
call the retailers but the retailers
usually do not have good Inventory
management systems and they do not know
how to manage inventory well and so what
Saturn says is that I'll change the way
we work with you let me because I'm
Saturn I have lots of high power
operations researchers scientists
statisticians to do the forecasting
management to I manag inventory for you
but in Return Of Course once I manage
your inventory I should provide you with
some protection so if you discover that
you're out of stock I help you to get
the inventory from other Saturn dealers
pooling pooling inventory if you have
too much inventory I take the inventory
back at some later point in time
obsolesence protection and I will
measure my own people not on how well
they serve you but on how well you serve
the end consumers I changed the
performance measures now that is a
business relationship change and the
resulted in Saturn at the time when
Saturn was still a viable company
separate company they are often times JD
Powers darling they perform much better
than the expensive car Lexus Infinity
Cadillac and Lincoln and the retailers
also benefit because the retailers
inventory turn average seven is much
much better than the industry average
everyone gains so business relationship
Innovation nasle recognized that if they
are sorting from the developing
economies the farmers in all these poor
countries it's not just good enough for
them to give them a fair price it's not
just good enough for them to help them
to use the right fertilizers but it's to
help the farmers Community to grow to
help the community with Safe Drinking
Water to create education facility
school systems and so on water treatment
plans because if the
farmers household is better off if they
don't have sick children if their
families are happy the farmers would be
better Farmers the farmers better
farmers will in turn become better
suppliers to nle so this is what I
called Share value it's a business
relationship in this case the business
relationship goes beyond company to
company company to supplier but more on
the whole Community the complete
ecosystem final example is Bhutan this
is hes not example Daniel spitzler a
former graduate of Stanford University
recognized that it's important to
develop hazelnut supply chain because
hazelnut is a great crop that the world
likes consumers like but we don't have
enough so he wanted to grow hazon nuts
in Bhutan but it's very difficult to
grow hazut in bhan so he created the
value chain which started with Nursery
um in bhan but also the seed culture in
yunan but how can you get the farmers to
grow he or not and he came up with a new
business relationship the business
relationship is not to ask the farmers
to buy the ha on nuts but give it to
them free of charge because the farmers
are so poor that even if you ask them to
buy in a low cost they could not afford
it give them free of charge help them
help them to grow it train them
irrigation and so on and then when they
are successful in growing the nuts buy
them from from them but he also promised
25% of the profits would be given back
to the local communities in that way he
builds up the ecosystem he make everyone
happy supportive of his new business and
he thinks that at fale the company is up
and
but full scale this would be 15% of the
employment of bhan will be alleviated
property alleviation so he's now working
and the good thing is that he's also
growing auts
on simply deforested slopes which enable
them to restore the forest back restore
vegetation back see again this is an
ecosystem Innovation this is a business
relationship Innovation a new way of
dealing with Farmers which is
unprecedented and then there could be
great great great gains so so I'm happy
to share with you these six innovations
that are exploiting how we can work
inside the ecosystem and I hope that you
all maybe can go back and take a look at
your respective situations and sometimes
it could be your existing company and
sometimes it could be your new companies
that you're building and starting up but
don't just look for product Innovations
in terms of functionalities and
performances inside the product but
think about the inter relationship in
the ecosystem Thank you very K back to
you I'd like to move on to our question
and answer uh period here so the first
question uh that I'd like to uh direct
to Professor Lee um from your point of
view which would be a good example of an
integrated planning of integrated
planning within an
organization thanks very much for the
questions in fact um one thing about the
value chain um integration is that
sometimes we also need to make sure we
have functional integration as well in
addition to company to comp integration
um what I found is that you start with
first functional integration which means
that within the company integrated
planning must be a collaboration between
product developments between people who
are in procurements and the
manufacturing as well as distribution
and all the way to after sales surfice
support so that constitute the
integrated planning integrated planning
would res in when you introduce a new
product you already have ahead of time
the logistic support and the after sales
service support all in place and so I
think that's a functional integration
and of course I think once we talk about
uh then involving the suppliers or
within the customers the integrated
planning often times will be to share
the road map and share the product uh
introduction plan so that they would be
alerted they would be aware they would
be participating in the whole plan
process as well so I work with Cisco a
lot and Cisco has been a terrific
company in being able to integrate from
product introduction and development all
the way to manufacturing and working
with their contract manufacturers and
service providers all the way to rolling
out to the end of life as well so I
think this is very powerful functional
integration first and then cross
Enterprise
Integration thank you uh another
question here um is there a methodology
to find the best value chain
optimization applied to a specific
case thank you for the question I think
the um I I I I oftentimes would ask um
companies to map the whole value chain
look at the whole value chain and then
um look at how the things flow the
information flow how how do information
flow in in this value chain and how do
you flow your materials and how do you
do your financial flow and think about
whether those flows can be synchronized
better so I think this is an exercise
simple exercise and drawing the flows
and seeing how flows go through your
value chain and see whether the
financial flow and the information flow
and the material flow can be
reconfigured yeah often times people
think that the three flows must go
together that's not necessary in fact
some of the Innovations happen is
because sometimes you do information
before material or sometimes you change
the sequence of the flow so I would say
the methodology is to start with a flow
diagram a map and then see where those
flows can be reconvicted
better okay it's great we have a number
of questions here how how does one go
about ecosystem map and looking for
opportunities within the value chain
yeah so this is great because ecosystem
is a huge huge uh one for any company
right you so you you don't want to put
that the whole kitchen sink and every
single entity in it so it's often times
I would say interestingly is that
depending on what product segment that
you're talking about the ecosystem would
change in a company think about a
company of HP a large company like HP
and Cisco that type or Google so for
particular product segments the
ecosystem will be different different so
you have to highlight the important ones
first the important ones and start with
that so I think that you definitely have
to use the 8020 rule of what would be
the 80% of the ecosystem the the the the
20% of the ecosystem that represents the
80% of the values uh and also impact uh
that would uh affect you to start with
so I would say definitely we have to
start with uh zeroing in on the top ones
first
great uh how do you see the uh sort of
e-commerce as an integrating element in
the asia-pacific value chain and how
much does it matter uh in today's
ecosystem good good one especially um
having having visited Asia so many times
recently I think the escalation of
e-commerce is an undeniable fact it's a
force it's that e-commerce is going to
be a significant one now but because of
e-commerce I think there are several
nice trends that has uh happened which
really resulted in a tighter integration
of the value chain or the need for doing
so so one is the information integration
because e-commerce uh you you're talking
about cycle times that are very
different from before that customers can
order an Apple iPhone and accessory here
anywhere in the world and and the
manufacturers in China has to receive
that and be able to distribute and put
things together quickly so e-commerce
has squeezed the information cycle to
unprecedented level which means that you
have to work much harder on the linkages
in information the second one is that
you still have to deliver the products
eCommerce of course there are some
information content products but there
are a lot of products that still have
physical how can you integrate with your
Logistics providers the manufacturers
that integrate with the UPS of the world
with the DXL and uh and Federal Express
as well as US Postal Service as well as
your own carriers and Google has come up
with a new way of doing delivery and so
the physical world also needs needs to
be integrated both in the information
world and the integrated world and the
third one is the integration of the
financial world that companies are
becoming to a new way uh companies
startup companies which is a very very
successful company both in China as well
as in the US are coming up with new
payment schemes that would allow company
to company individual to individual
payment transfer in much more efficient
and reliable manner so I think
e-commerce is result in the acceleration
of these kind of free
flows next question do you think lean
has a place uh in value chain Innovation
and optimization absolutely I think this
is very very crucial because I think we
start with even in the number one uh
Innovation that I mentioned is the
within note Innovation within note
Innovation is you start with making sure
that the processes that you yourself
manage must be efficient and lean is a
very good concept to do so because lean
of course you don't want to do lean at
the expense of everything else but I
think it still it get you the focus on
how to get things done the nonv value
added activities would go away the way
stage would go away and so that's lean
concept what we do need to apply lean is
now to apply lean to the complete value
chain that companyto compan interaction
some of the steps are necessary some of
the crossb signatures may not be
necessary how can we also apply the lean
concept so that the complete value chain
in the the logistics linkages and the
cross water linkages can also be as
efficient as possible so I I think
absolutely lean is a core to valuing
Innovation and we'll take one last
question um how do you deal with
complaints that Innovations will put
people out of work uh fears that
Innovations will make fewer employees
necessary I think this is a a good
question and what I hope we would also
use the perspective is that Innovation
often times is not just innovating in
one segment and then
uh eliminating another segment so so
that's one way of looking at Innovation
that sometimes often happens is that one
segment so for instance robotic
advancements and the uh machineries and
Automation and so on resulted in the
segment of the ordinary Labor uh being
pH out so that's one segment hurting the
other segment the other kind of
innovation and some of the examples that
I used like Bhutan hazelet growth uh
kind of examples are Innovations where
multiple sectors get benefits and in
fact in some cases is the transferal
that the Bhutan Farmers used to grow
something that are non value added High
not high values but now they're growing
hazel nuts which are high value so that
sment is still there except they're
doing something different so I'm hoping
that you also think of Innovations where
multi segment get benefit at the same
time because one segment was not face
out they were just changed to doing
something different and I hope that's
the kind of innovation no question that
there are some innovation that are
substitution but I hope we also the the
at The Innovation level we are at the
Innovation level where Innovation
benefits multiple segments of the world
and that is how we can make true
progress thank you so much um Professor
Lee for for joining us today so thank
you everyone and uh thank you again for
joining us and have a great rest of your
day